Tyler: ADMIT IT!
YOU'RE GARBAGE!
Ethan: YOU'RE THE WORST YOUTUBER IN THE WORLD!
Mark: NO! IT'S NOT TRUE!
LOOK! IT'S A BUSY WEEK! I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIMEE!!!
Tyler: Excuses, excuses.
Mark: NO! GUYS! NO!
Oh, hey
Hi, how's it goin'?
I've got a lot of blood rushing to my head, but uh
*ding* This week's gonna be really busy because
We're filming a GREAT big video
that I'm not gonna tell you exactly what it is
But this isn't one of those empty promises
Because it's coming out next week *ding*
I'm not gonna give too many details about it
But, since we're working so hard on it this week *ding*
I'm only gonna be able to get one video out a day this week *ding*
I'm sorry, it should be back to normal on Saturday
If we're all finished up by then
But until then, it's just gonna be one video a day
I'm so sorry about that-
I'M SO SORRY GUYS!
(Tyler and Ethan laughing) LET GO OF ME! AHHHH!
Byee!